[Music]
we're going to start with a lecture and
today's topic is how to take advantage
of all kinds of chess advantages we have
sometimes we have let's say the
initiative we have push we have a chance
to to push forward because a position is
better it could be because of
development it can be because a material
advantage this time the example that
we're stalling with today shows us an
advantage of two bishops we look at the
position we see that block has two
bishops and white only has a bishop and
a knight we know that they're worth
about the same three points but in an
open position with pawns that the
position is really open up pawns on both
sides of the board bishops can become
really really powerful and very very
agile in this position some of you might
say well we look at the position we
think maybe it's equal each side has six
bonds and the same amount of material
but if you show this to a master or a
grandmaster they will say now I don't
think so they're gonna say definitely
black is better because this bishop on
CA that looks really boring and sleepy
he is gonna become very very strong and
white doesn't have a light square Bishop
to counter it if you take this night
away and you put a bishop here let's say
a white bishop here then of course the
assessment of the position would change
completely definitely in White's favor
he's going to be better develop and he's
gonna have the same two bishops as black
so in this position which was played by
a very first world champion Willem
steinitz you will see an example of how
to use the two bishops very much in our
favor so step by step first of all he
looks at the position and says well
white has a reason to be proud of one
piece and one piece only which one is
that who could tell me yes oh yes the
knight on d4 sitting pretty on a nice
square it looks like right all the other
pieces are not very impressive so step
one kick it out immediately sending the
knight back alright so the knight is
being kicked not that many good squares
to go to if he goes on the Queen side
anyways black wants to play the move be
sick
as you will see see if you go Knight b3
it stop will be helping your cause a lot
he tried to play Knight after he and
again the point is not so much to
analyze the game in great detail and see
if really there's a big improvement for
white somewhere during the game the
point is to show how to take advantage
of a superiority and again in this
position it's black to move and if you
were black I don't know what you guys
will have played but I think that they
moved at the world champion that first
world champion played was very very good
he immediately thinks okay my advantage
is having a light square bishop or my
opponent doesn't have one and if I could
put it use my imaginary hand and just
put it anywhere on the board where would
I'd like it to be do I want it to be on
this diagonal don't want it to be on
this diagonal don't want to be in this
diagonal or don't want to be somewhere
else and he thought okay the most
threatening diagonal is the longest
diagonal the h1 a a diagonal and I'm
going to put it right there and how am I
going to do it I'm gonna do it by
playing the move b6 first of all I'm
protecting the pot on c5 a and my bishop
is ready to come to b7 as my plan once
the bishop comes to b7 he is going to be
almost like a dragon Bishop attacking
the whole bag you know nothing to
counter it white is a very very passive
position notice that my Queen right now
is very annoying nagging in the pawn on
a 2 for example that's one thing so if
you just play simple chests you will
probably just lose if you just try to
play something that it's a h3 Bishop b7
King h1 I'm just gonna advance just take
control of the file with both my rooks
my queen is going to be attacking all
the pawns if you ever try to defend them
then this bishop will open up just bad
news so white tries to play a clever
move 95 okay I understand that move you
want to a make the Queen move it away
from its superior post on c4 and you are
praying the the bishop will take it now
this I want to bring into consideration
one thing that I see a lot in scholastic
chests many times I see players simply
trade a lot they tend to trade pieces
they say you know what
PCs attacking me let me just get rid of
it okay sometimes the piece is so well
placed or so threatening or so superior
that yes you want to get rid of it you
just want to eliminate it and that's
understandable but in a position like
this you have to really think twice like
the knight looks really impressive on e5
but there's several things that you need
to think about a this Bishop is super
valuable there is no way I'm trading
this guy for this guy second of all my
queen can just redraw back without much
consequence and third of all the knight
isn't gonna stay here forever you didn't
stay here forever because they had a
pawn to kick it out and it's not gonna
stay here forever because I have a pawn
to kick it out and I can always
reposition my bishop should I need to so
Bishop takes Knight would be a really
bad move completely giving away
everything you have and again it looks
like such an easy decision it's almost
like you have a burden my not the knight
is attacking my queen all I have to do
is take it if I took it all my worries
of the world will go away and that is a
very bad where you're thinking because
you don't think of what you have what
you have is a monster Bishop and just
play a simple move like Queenie six and
the same worries of the world are off
this way so no need to go crazy and just
give up an advantage for the panic of oh
my god my queen he's under attack so now
again I want to play Bishop to b7 with a
monster Bishop so Y tries to play Queen
f3 again I think a very understandable
move in my opinion the Queen is trying
to control the diagonal first and attack
the rock in the corner of course you
cannot play Bishop e7 and again if you
try to be tricky and play rook b8 with
the idea of Bishop e7 96 is very
annoying and I'm sure you can see that
in the variation rook to b8 Knight to c6
Bishop b7 at first it look ha I tricked
my opponent I pinned the night but the
night is going to go Knight takes d 8
unpinning because the knight is also
attacking this Queen and block is just
losing so that's going to be really
terrible so black says okay I'll play
the only move that I have the only
sensible move the time but it's good
enough Bishop a6 connecting my rooks
developing my Bishop this way of course
I have known
of living the bishop on this boring
diagonal but I'm just going to do things
at my own pace because I could not play
there should be seven so now I also have
to bring into consideration that once
the rook leaves the F file I might have
a choice at some point to play Bishop
takes pawn pawn takes Queen takes
because not all I'm not just trading I'm
winning material so white played
reasonably read rook to e1 the rookies
opposite the Queen so now comes the next
next phase in the printer plan
pawn to f6 in this position he is
kicking the night away the knight is
cannot be tolerated on e5 he's just
doing too much damage and the knight
says okay well if I go to c6 who knows
if I'll ever see the light of day right
like rook c8 and what's gonna be
happening now who's gonna defend the
nine so he has to bring Knight to the
only other square that is safe which is
on g4 and black says okay on we go h5
clicking the knight further and the
knight has only one good square here so
with two simple moves that improve the
position on the King side it might look
like we weakened things a little bit but
you'll see that black is fixing things
in about one second but with two simple
moves we kick the knight all the way
from a 5 - f - so from being a proud
knight it's now probably one of the
worst pieces on the board now in this
position again black is to think of a
plan
he has to worry about two different
things one at some point white might
play the move f5 which needs to
definitely be considered because after
Queen takes we trade Queens and the pawn
structure looks really funny and if you
play pawn takes then the Queen might
take on h5 that looks even worse and
also remember we really really really
feel like having our bishop on the long
diagonal the bishop is doing absolutely
nothing here I want to play Bishop e7
but the Queen now is going to take it so
that brings us to the next movement very
easily we can understand why it was
played by black he moves away the Queen
from danger he over protects his pawn on
h5 and he
take the square on b7 to enable himself
to play Bishop to b7 watch Queen f7
beautiful sometimes you know you look at
this position if I just left this
position with you and say okay block to
move what would you play you might
suggest 10 different reasonable moves
but in my opinion this is really an
unmoved because it's a like it's a
simple retreat but it's what we call in
just an aggressive retreat
you're not just retreating for ii of
backing down or backing off but you are
going to be a very aggressive in a
second so the queen is just sitting and
waiting in ambush just waiting for the
proper moment to get back into the game
and boy is this queen gonna cause
trouble you will see now the point is
the queen is in touch with the h pawn
and supporting b7 so white plays f5
again I think the most aggressive move
what else
b3 was another choice but I think that
you play b3 you just open up things for
the other Bishop and now of course F
takes G six is very very annoying so
black simply plays g5 for one moment we
might say hey Aviv what did you do to
the bishop on g7 it looks horrible and
I'm gonna say just wait patience the
element of time is important but not
super important in this position now
White has to think to himself okay what
do I do next my bishop or e3 is really
not a good Bishop my knight doesn't have
that many good squares to go to and in
any event Bishop e7 is coming right now
so he says okay rook t1 time to fight
for the file if not Bishop e7 and look
up and the other rook over it's just
gonna give black a very easy game
needless to say that I don't wanna even
hear about the Queen taking this pawn
ever because several reasons first of
all in this position rook is going to
come back to a-1 may be embarrassing the
bishop a little bit maybe Queen C for B
3 and that can be just bad news but in
the very least we have Queen takes h5
all the time the Queen is kind of in
touch with this pawn so first things
Bishop to b7 Queen moves away and now
the Queen let go of h5 and now again
some of you might say hey now
the queen is not in touch with age five
and the bishop moved from the a file can
we just take this pawn on a - well this
is part of the lesson for today when you
have a good position like you have now
don't give your opponent unnecessary
counterplay don't give him a chance to
get active in this position the white
pieces are just like one big mess
the knight isn't going anywhere the
bishop on e3 looks like just one fat
pawn and the Queen on g3 is not doing
anything aggressive let's not take a
silly put on a two which is not going to
help us right now we're not going to
Queen upon or anything that's only going
to be a factor later on but if you take
the pollen 82 then he's gonna go Queen
c7 immediately EE attacking the rook on
d8 attacking the bishop on b7 and the
Queen becomes super active so for
example let's take a look at the
variation as its mentioned if takes
Queen c7 you have to give up the file
because otherwise you're gonna lose
material rook takes now you have to save
the bishop so Bishop d5 and already we
considered for one pawn white owns the
file his queen is aggressive and the
black queen is somewhere on a to doing
god-knows-what and now we can play
something like Queen d7 and it's like
what the heck happened Black is just
defending and defending and defending
and it's like what did he do nothing
good so no no way he's gonna take the
pawn instead he's gonna say to himself
okay how can I improve my position if
I'm not gonna go pawn hunting what am I
going to do and here is how we get to
the move okay
this Bishop right now is not that good
but I don't have a great way of
activating it I saw like I can just pick
up this Bishop on g7 and put it
somewhere good if I can play Bishop e5 I
will definitely do it however that's not
very vigor so I'm thinking okay I have
to wait with my bishop we have to be
patience patient what do we do and I'm
thinking okay what else can I improve in
my position I really don't like my rook
on a eight what is he doing it's not
doing much but if I played rook c8 or
rook b8 did I help the cause now so I
have to basically understand that in
order to activate the a work I have to
do something with my dear work and
that's what are we gonna do rook to d5
fantastic
we're preparing the doubling of the
ropes the other rookies ready to come
right to d8 and become one of the more
active pieces in the game and also
remember that pawn on f5 we're kind of
looking to hunt for it if I have a
chance to take it I will definitely take
it so again white is thinking what am I
gonna do how am I going to protect that
pot on D on f5 this is not so easy so he
plays rook takes Queen takes our Queen
that was sitting in waiting now came out
of the ambush and look at this battery
when we have a Queen and Bishop on the
same diagonal like this we say it's a
battery and this is a fantastic battery
along the long diagonal the poor Queen
is completely tied down to defense again
they can defend against their mate this
is not this is not happy news what did
you sow in the game he went rogue d1 if
you would have played Queen h3 at first
you think hey that's a great solution
defend the pawn on f5 and attack the
pawn on h5 but again quickly remember
that the Queen is completely tied down
to the mate all I have to do is tickle
it and the Queen is already kind of
stuck I cannot take the pollen Age 5
because twin takes GT looks like mate
bad news so he plays rook to d1 and now
thank you very much that's my pawn so
already we can see the blacks very
simple strategy gave him an extra pawn
but that's not the end of the game and
already is very happy to good bishops do
we know that this Bishop is going to
open up at some point but this Bishop is
just with no counter now white can just
play normal chess and lose or you can
try to be a little active which he tries
again Queen 2 here but unlike before now
I can play Bishop b5 and notice that my
queen is very well placed it's not
somewhere vacationing far away it's
right in the business of things right
here so there's no Queen d7 or any
follow up so pawn to b3 or else we're
gonna lose more pawns on the Queen side
and black again brings the last piece
that's not playing right into the game
rook e8
and you can see that the bishop on e3 is
a target and what to do with this bishop
the only way to do something with it is
go backwards so
before you do that white tries to again
make things a little more spicy trying
to say hey maybe he's gonna trade his
bishop for my Bishop of course as black
says no way in the world that Bishop on
f7 has great future even if I'm going to
have to send it to a worse spot for a
moment it's still gonna have a great
future
while this bishop on c1 is just a lame
bishop so Bishop f7 Bishop c1 saving the
bishop and we on we go rookie to notice
how in two moves the sleepy rook from
the corner goes right into the thick of
things and become maybe the most
influential piece in the black army in
two simple moves that cost no time okay
now the knight is attacked and also a2
is under attack rook f1 defending stuff
and again black gives white no relief at
all Queen c2 now that the threat is to
bother the over occupied rook by playing
rook takes Knight when the roof is
lifted up wind the bishop on c1 winning
two minor pieces for a rock what a bad
position for white really terrible in
the game he played Queen to g3 bringing
the Queen back trying to protect his
knight but in this position black simply
took the pollinate you and that was the
end of that now I'm not telling you to
resign in the position like this when
you just down a little material and the
grand master level they just respect
each other and say okay I know that they
have nothing but if you look at the
position it's really not fun to play
with white like my knight has very few
moves my bishop has practically no moves
and all my pawns are weak the bishops
are going to be revived and notice how
beautiful the King is of course this is
a completely winning position from bikes
point of view so resigning with white is
not not ridiculous at all okay did you
understand the example okay good
on we go to the next one and I'm going
to skip this one for a moment and I'm
gonna go with this one okay
this is a position that I really love
showing my students and again it's a
kind of position but I do with many of
my positions that I think you can show
players that are strong masters I've
shown this position to twenty to twenty
three hundred and I've shown this
position to our two players who are even
lower than you guys you know at all
levels basically and the thing is you
can always learn something from those
positions here let's take a look at the
position understand this is a somewhat
of an ending a technical position and
I'm sure that you can see that white
isn't a real significant advantage he
really has a great why first of all you
should know that when there's a bishop
against night when pawns on both sides
of the board assuming that the bishop is
not blocked by its pawns or some other
extreme example then the bishop is much
better than the knight is just more
agile the knight can be really clumsy
like for example here you'll notice that
the knight has no good moves I can't go
forward anywhere I'm really stuck very
limited when this bishop is already
looking at the pawn and when a bishop
tells the Queen stay that's almost
always a good thing because black
instead of activating his queen has to
do just babysitting job on the pawn so
if this would have been if Mike the
diplay were the white pieces his
Grandmaster Mikhail Botvinnik who was a
world champion and a very very
methodical player but you will see that
even he sometimes has a little lapse of
concentration in this position he should
be winning I think in the long run and
all year to do is play like Bishop f3
bring his queen up I King up play g4 h4
at the right time g5 and he's
controlling both sides of the board the
opponent can do nothing you're really
stuck because if you push one pawn then
my bishop gets all the light squares and
if you push the other one I'm just gonna
take it so really really a bad position
for for black I would say that the de
Grandmaster loveth the world
championship level black will suffer
forever and probably lose in the end
but in our game we played the move
before and okay I mean this move doesn't
look to change things too much you think
what's the difference
this looks like even more logical now if
black plays c5
we're gonna play b5 completely control
the light squares then our Bishop is
gonna come here and black is like
running out of moves his knife is going
nowhere
his queen can go nowhere I can always
hide with my King if I need to and again
in the long run it looks like just a fun
position to play for white so black said
okay I'm in trouble
but whites last move of b4 gives me a
chance to do something that before I
could not have done when the pawn was on
b3 and watch what he does he managed to
get a get activity and make the most out
of what he has in the position his next
move must come as a surprise to all of
you when when I show it to my students
and they don't solve it and I showed him
the idea they're like wow that's really
that's pretty clever so I want you to
take like a mental picture of this
position like try to edge it in your
mind look in it and then you'll see what
happened in just a few more moves and
you'll see how black improved this
position and the move that he played was
D 5
it looks like suicide what is he doing
not only is here the Queen is stuck
defending the c6 pawn he's just pitching
upon it just like take my pawns and if
you take the pawn it looks like pawn
takes pawn takes Bishop takes and then
the Queen comes to e6 it looks like what
is he doing he trying to lose fast or
what but no there is a logic behind it
after pawn takes he is absolutely no
intention of taking this pawn and
opening up the bishop but he's playing
c5 a fantastic idea really really a
really clever idea he gave up one pawn
and what did he achieve one he
completely blockaded the bishop to his
knight which is the best locator has a
beautiful spot on d6
this is an extra pawn but he is not
queening there is no way in the world
that the white forces can make the pawn
go to d6 without just losing it and in
the meantime he manages to get himself a
protected passport and at least a
protected upon a passed pawn on the C
file that's going to keep the white
forces quite busy so again from this
position if the pawn was on b3 this
wouldn't work because after c5 the pond
is not passed I'm just not looking
to advance it so once he played b4 pon
takes c5 excellent cell takes takes
white is up upon but all of a sudden
black has a world of counter play watch
what happens
Bishop f1 96 the sleepy night that had
no moves is all of a sudden right down
next to the center he's already
attacking for example the pawn here he's
controlling some important squares most
importantly he is gonna force this pawn
to be pushed so queen a3 again trying to
play four tricks
if c4 then maybe Bishop takes c4 if you
them takes you can't take with the night
because it's pinned if you take with the
Queen Queen takes d6 check that could be
really bad news for black so black says
okay I'm moving away from the pin and
improving my position of the king so
Bishop d3 defending the pawn on f5 see
for Bishop c2 and now he could have done
all kinds of things that Queen b6 in one
line it was mentioned was check here and
here also a good line where black is
completely active and there is no way in
the world that he's gonna be worse here
but in the game what he did was also
good he played c3 and again notice what
happened in just several moves black is
a very very good passport that keeps
white super busy his bishop from being a
monster bishop that was keeping the poor
Queen in touch with a pawn babysitting
it forever his all of a sudden just a
block header and the sleepy night that
had no moves is now block heading this
pawn and he didn't even say the last
word he's still gonna advance so Queen
before trying to improve the position
Knight c4 again an excellent move and
the point is after Queen see three Queen
c5 check King h1 Queen takes d5 check he
traded the C pawn that wasn't advancing
anymore for the D pawn and of course in
this position white agree to a draw
because he knows that after King g1
queen c5 Chuck he has nothing the Queen
and Knight are just too strong at the
very least with a
expos king I'm always going to have a
perpetual on what kind of an extra pawn
is that nothing
so from absolutely a terrible position
for white for black with one tiny move
of B for the position change and black
was very smart to take full advantage of
it I really think I haven't seen many
examples like this lately where from a
position where you completely smothered
with no moves you just do something like
this and look for the cost of one little
pawn improve your position enough that
your opponent has to play accurately to
make a draw that is good success okay
our last position for the day before
we're going to get to play some chess is
actually from one of my games I don't
really like to show many of my games but
sometimes I do this is a position where
I play the Hedgehog and I get into this
position with black and I've thought of
myself you know my positions piece but
my opponent's pieces look really funny
one night is on c2 the other night is on
b2 there's a bishop on b4 that's kind of
stuck with my own pizza standing in
front of it and I felt that with all the
pieces on the queenside something has to
happen in the center slash kingside so
in this position what do you think what
do you think block should do here I'm
gonna be quiet for just one minute and
those of you watch it and YouTube can
just pause for a second as well but
those of you in class what do you think
I should do in this position
take a look I'm not gonna give you too
much time I'm gonna be it's gonna be a
little unfair to you because I had lots
of time to think about what I want to do
and I'm kind of putting you on the spot
but this is that kind of a question it's
an exercise in intuition just
intuitively what do you think blacks
should do you look at the position and
you think okay the most normal move the
most sedated move would be to play rook
F to c8 and if you thought about this
move then you did well that's a very
good nur who can complain about such a
logical man but I thought to myself that
while I have the opportunity
maybe I should grab it because when I
calculated it I could see nothing wrong
with it
and I said to myself I think this is a
pretty a pretty safe continuation it's a
very small risk that I'm taking so what
do you guys think I want somebody to
raise their hand
and suggest a move only one person has
an idea I promise you one thing if
you're wrong I'm not gonna throw any
chairs with you how about that is that a
good trade
okay Arjun what do you think say again I
like that move Knight C takes e4 again
it looks like the White King is a little
bit unsafe all the pieces are on this
side and sometimes people say hey what
about playing d5 and striking and I'm
like d5 maybe e5 and then the knight is
being chased away and the other night is
gonna find a beautiful home on d4 so as
much as I really want to play d5 open up
the bishop hit the center I don't think
it's just enough
however sacrificing is a really good
idea so well what can you do you have to
take or else you down upon so pawn takes
Knight takes and now we can see that for
a minimal investment of a piece for two
pawns black got a ton of activity now
the weakness of all the white pieces
comes into play because first of all I
have a very nasty discovered shock all I
want to do is move this night somewhere
painful right for example Knight g5
looks like a very serious move mainly
because after King g19 h3 check King f1
Queen each one is going to be checkmate
so the King is really really unhappy on
g2
so he's got to do something about it of
course King to here Knight check and the
King is gonna go on a trip I think
one-way ticket right we're gonna be very
unlikely it's gonna save itself so he
tried to play the move King g1 okay so
of course I saw thus far and here I
remember that originally I thought of
one thing and then I said to myself well
I could still play this move but one Don
I first play something else so if you
guys suggested Knight g5 with the idea
of playing Knight h3 which is very very
strong of course you'd be okay but I
said to myself this is not going away
and in the meantime this is looking so
funny
let me take advantage of it and I played
Bishop f6 so my bishop is now into the
game and it's very very important
control this diagonal and now what to do
about this night you know the night
doesn't have too many good move
especially when there's a rock behind it
also so it's a bit pinned and my
opponent played the move Knight d4 well
I think this is not a great move but
it's really hard to suggest anything
good for example if you would have
played rugby one at a minimum I could
have played the move like Bishop c3 and
if he takes Knight takes is just forking
everything and again my g5 still is also
a very good choice where I improve my
position of the bishop and he just
played Brooke from a1 to be one so in
any event he tried to play aggressively
with 94 and of course 9 g5
and in this position you can see that
there's already lots and lots of trouble
really really a real problematic
position my opponent originally told me
that they plan to play h4 but after h4
well in the game of the D plays for no
play Queen GT right if h4 what would
have happened Bishop takes d4 check rook
takes d4 Knight f3 check and Knight
takes rook
so already the bishop that came to the
long diagonal proves quite strong so
Queen g2 unfortunately again this
doesn't change a whole lot in the
position because again black simply
played takes takes Knight f3 check one
more time King here 90s d4 Bishop takes
d6 again maybe for a moment that looked
like a really good solution because the
bishop is forking 2 rooks but again
everything happens with time check and
check and of course my opponent was
stuck now down in exchange and the pawn
and of course not much hope and resign
of course I can move my rock you can
just take the knight and be up a piece
so again in a position where all the
pieces are concentrating on one side of
the board with absolutely nothing
productive happening and there's a
weakness in the King side / Center don't
be afraid to do something sometimes it's
a strike in the center sometimes it's a
sacrifice in this position he resists a
simple sacrifice
again you lose a light for two points
but you get a world of compensation for
it like you saw in this example okay so
we are just past the halfway time of the
lesson I guess this is time to let you
play as well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]